Before I started playing electric guitar
people just titled my music as folk
music which I thought was bizarre
but now that I don't play as much
acoustic, people say it's
indie. (I used to have long
hair). I wanted to learn about the
independent music scene and the
communities where the genre comes from,
so I partnered with my friends over at
INDIE ALASKA to show me one Alaskan
artist's story.
Quinn Christopherson is a young musician
born and raised in the Last Frontier.
After making independent music in
Anchorage for years he rose to relative
stardom in 2019
when he won the NPR Tiny Desk Concert
contest.
So Quinn if I wanted to make an indie
song, what exactly
would I do? What steps would I take to
make a complete indie song? If you wanted
to make an indie song,
I would tell you to pick someone you
love
and that you want to write about and
write a song about them.
Or a poem, start there. So question for
you Quinn, do you think we should
collaborate on a song together?
Yeah absolutely. Let's get it. Let's do it.
I have a feeling that, you know, you're
just gonna bring something special
to the table.
okay thank you thank you. I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try my darndest.
To bring it to the indie table! That is indie!
Right? While we work on that song
together, let's learn more about the
indie music scene.
Before indie described a band's sound,
independent music was just that,
independent. Taking a page from punk
rockers before them in the 70's,
indie bands followed the do-it-yourself
ethos of self-reliance
and operating outside the mainstream
music culture.
Since indie describes a band's outlook
more than their musical style,
independent musicians can range from the
electronic soul style of Frank Ocean,
to the lyrical and melancholy sounds of
The Smiths.
And like most genres, sound and style is
greatly influenced
by location.
To learn more about the history of the
music scene in Alaska
we spoke with Kurt Riemann, the owner of
Surreal Studios,
the oldest recording studio in Anchorage.
Every piece of music in Alaska is
independent music.
There's no label supporting
anything in Alaska.
So the people that stay here are people
that are
very fiercely, independently Alaskanites
who take whatever it is they're working
on whether it's folk or punk or rock
or electronic or whatever and
put their own independent spin on it. In
another 50 to 100 years it's going to be
seen as the folk music of the time.
Quinn acknowledges that his sudden rise
to fame might be considered an anomaly
in the independent music industry.
I kind of like skipped a lot of steps.
Person wins this contest and then
they're like
in this like world all of a sudden, which
is I think unique. Other indie musicians
they make a record, do it theirself,
upload it and then maybe a record label
gets hold of it and it's like, oh, we, you
know, will like this, we'll release this.
And then they kind of get their start
from there.
Before, I was working a full-time
job
and my music was solely kind of like
this therapy thing
and my songs are kind of crushing in
that way. And I think
now that I've been able to give my full
self
and like my work hours to my music I've
been able to
like experience it and use it in in all
sorts of different
emotions that I didn't before so I
think it's definitely
changed. (All the things you've done
for me, I hope I can do
some for you). Songs with dark somber
lyrics
are common all over mainstream music
right now. Just look at the popularity of
musicians like Lana Del Rey
and Post Malone, and recently when Billie
Eilish made history
at the 2020 Grammys by collecting six of
the seven top awards
with her album that she recorded in her
brother's bedroom in their family home.
Clearly, people are drawn to this style.
In the indie music scene
a DIY style of recording music is common.
Quinn told us he once recorded a song by
putting a sock over a microphone.
Indie music also tends to be more
sonically adventurous or experimental.
Some independent bands like Neutral Milk Hotel sound purposefully raw
with pitchy vocals and over modulated
instrumental sections.
Hey Quinn tell me about your
time when you
entered the Tiny Desk Competition and
you won. What was that like?
Best thing that's ever happened to me for sure.
It was like
seriously amazing. We entered last year
and I say we cause it's like a community
affair, like making a video and
putting it together and putting it out.
(I'm tired of people trying to
erase me)
It was just crazy. I'm just gonna tune up
this guitar.
Looking at you Bob, because
I don't know if you know this but when
you called me and you told me
you won I got off the phone and I
thought, dang I should buy a guitar.
Legit did not have one.
But that's Anchorage. That's the music
community there. Everyone just borrowed
me their stuff
long term. It was
unreal. Everybody hot has to hit
Tiny Desk.
Oh my god. Tiny Desk is like the
stage.
So Quinn what inspires the themes that
you
put into your music. Life experiences.
I feel like i'm a storyteller (Storytelling!).
Yeah I like telling stories and
pulling from like people I love and
people I know and
and that sort of thing. So quinn should
we check out this song? Should we see how
it's going?
Let's listen to it. But I didn't
have a mic, I didn't have an overhead
so it's gonna be like a real washy like
a weirdly miced
indie kind of thing. Okay that's perfect!
Let's get into it.
Yeah, that's way more vibrant already.
I play with the bass though.
(He got me my own ball and matching shoes)
(I was a real bad sport. I never liked to lose)
(He kept showing up teaching me the rules)
(Oh my dad. Yeah he plays guitar. Says he knows more than he can do)
(He tells me that I do more than I know)
(He'd tell me don't be stupid when I hang with friends. And look me in the eye. My dad has always been a real smart guy)
I'm telling you when I recorded the
vocals I recorded them in my backyard
that's why all the birds and everything.
Oh! That stuff was real?! Yes! Oh I thought that was like...man.
No, I'm telling you and you hear in the
beginning of the song, "Kalia! Kalia!"
That's my neighbors' kids I think they're
just like playing.
And see that's the that's really the
the essence, the organic
essence. Yeah so the fact that you did
that on your end too is hilarious.
Do you think living in Alaska influences
your music at all?
Yeah I think the weather influences me
in general. It's just like so freaking dark
for like eight months,
you know? Yeah yeah yeah yeah. I think
that affects my writing for sure.
Despite indie music's current dark
streak, many artists these days
are open about their own mental health
and shed light on things like depression
and anxiety. I've been therapized
at a few shows. When I wrote those songs,
I was
playing for nobody. That was true therapy.
Now, pouring my heart out in front of
like strangers
and them just really willing to take me
in is so crazy. I
never thought that would happen in a
million years. So it's like, I'm really
grateful.
Quinn is currently working on his first
full-length album.